bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde en direct sur excepté au
sommaire ce soir ce pacte vert européen
qui divise les eurodéputés trop
ambitieux pour les uns pas assez pour
les autres la taxe carbone aux
frontières a été rejetée lors d'un vote
surprise aujourd'hui mais on
s'intéressera également à l'autre mesure
phare qu'est été adoptée celle à la fin
du moteur thermique dès 2035 comment va
s'opérer ce virage est ce qu'on l'a
vraiment anticiper grand décryptage dans
un instant avec nos invités elle a été
la chef d'orchestre d'une campagne qui
restera dans les mémoires l'intrigante
sarah knafo c'est le titre de l'ouvragé
que lui consacre des journalistes ava
djamshidi et françois delavier ménages
le grand reporter à tf1 sera notre
invité dans la seconde partie de
l'émission enfin nos a franchi ce soir
on prendra le pouls de la majorité
présidentielle à quelques jours du
premier tour des législatives avec elsa
mondain gaba emmanuel ducrocq nous
parlera de la hausse des prix à venir
dans les cantines scolaires et oui c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle enfin vincent le
jeu reviendra sur cette déclaration d'
emmanuel macron il ne faut pas humilier
la russie une petite phrase qui passe
mal dans le reste de l'europe vous le
verrez voilà pour le sommaire c'est
parti pour ça vous regarde
[Musique]
nom de code fit for fifty-five
l'objectif est ambitieux il s'agit de
réduire de 55 % les émissions de co2
d'ici à 2030 comment notamment en
passant au tout électrique dans la
voiture il n'y aura plus aucune voiture
neuve équipée de moteurs à essence en
2035 c'est donc ce qu'ont décidé les
députés européens aujourd'hui il faut
maintenant obtenir le feu vert de tous
les membres du conseil européen est avec
nous pour débattre de ce sujet crucial
mais complexe j'accueille richard wehrli
bonsoir notre couteau suisse si vous
savez que c'était mon expression vous
êtes journaliste pour la plateforme
blick chez nos amis helvètes marie
chiron bonsoir vous êtes membre de
transport et environnement c'est une
fédération qui regroupe une cinquantaine
de ngo au niveau européen qui sont
actives sur cette thématique du
transport propre cédric fréour bonsoir
cette journaliste aux échos spécialiste
des questions automobiles et puis on
accueillera dans un instant flavien
neuvy qui est économiste spécialiste du
secteur automobile
mais quand on parle d'europe c'est
toujours un peu compliqué heureusement
il y à stéphane blakowski pour nous
aider
[Musique]
bonsoir stephen alors on compte sur vous
pour y voir plus clair merci de votre
confiance
parce que si j'ai bien compris
aujourd'hui les députés européens
organes russes ya ça ne plante pas
réussi plutôt à se mettre d'accord sur
deux sujets très importants pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique c'est
la réforme de le ts et l'instauration d
emma cf ça y est vous êtes converti au
jargon européen qu'est ce qui se passe
là j'ai mon dossier en fait je fais un
peu le malin juste pour vous montrer que
moi c'est toujours un peu compliqué
effectivement quand on rentre dans le
coeur des dossiers ce matin j'étais
effectivement comme tout le monde enfin
comme la plupart des gens je ne savais
pas que le ts c'était en fait le marché
du carbone et notamment en europe et je
ne savais pas que les mas et f c'était
les taxe qu'on compte imposer aux
frontières pour que les chinois qui
viennent de shanghai en super tanker
payent une taxe sur leurs produits donc
pour essayer de dire plus simplement en
fait en rejetant cette première mesure
sur la réponse du marché dax carbone et
là deux autres qui se sont enchaînés en
fait le parlement européen les députés
européens ont bloqué bas deux des
principales mesures qui bloquent faire
nous permet d'atteindre l'objectif zéro
carbone 2050 ça veut dire donc que c'est
une défaite pour les écologistes en
toute logique
c'est pas si simple
expliquez moi on pourrait penser que
c'est une défaite pour l'écologie sauf
que les écologistes les verts et la
gauche ont voté contre ce texte
exactement comme l'extrême droite mais
pour des raisons complètement opposées
évidemment puisque les verts et la
gauche trouvait que ben on imposait pas
cette contrainte sur le marché du
carbone tam ont laissé trop de quotas
gratuits et puis à droite au contraire
l'extrême droite notamment disait qu'on
emmerde les gens avec toutes ces
histoires et les deux sont trouvé
d'accord pour voter contre le texte donc
on a fait remarquer aux insoumis qu'il
était d'accord avec l'extrême droite
vous imaginez bien que mal en brie
n'était pas contente
chi chi chi messieurs du ppe a voté avec
l'extrême droite qui a voté avec
l'extrême droite pour donner du pouvoir
aux lounges bout à bout c'est le
repousser la fin des quotas gratuits qui
aujourd'hui est responsable de du
reniement en matière climatique
c'est bien vu c'est bien vous vous
emmenons si vous du débat sur le
réchauffement climatique on en revient à
l'argument originel celui de la cour de
récréation c'est celui qui dit qui y est
c'est toi qui es d'accord avec extrême
c'est pas moi bon le résultat a
finalement de tout ça c'est qu'en fait
il ya une urgence climatique et que les
textes vont devoir attendre ils vont
être heureux nego fin retravailler en
commission vous risquez de trouver un
accord puis re propose watts mais plus
tard il ya quand même eu un vote
important aujourd'hui au parlement
européen sur la fin des voteurs tête des
moteurs thermiques en 2035 provoqué la
mort de près ses comparables européens
la fin des moteurs thermiques ça vient
qu'en 2035 on va obliger les
constructeurs européens en gros à
consentir une à vendre et donc
construire uniquement des voitures 100%
électriques vous aurez droit de rouler
si vous avez encore une thermique mais
pour en vendre ça sera interdit donc
pourquoi 2035 pourquoi tout ça
explications pascal canfin qui est le
patron de la commission environnement au
parlement pour être neutre en carbone en
2050 il faut arrêter de vendre des
voitures qui ne le sont pas
quinze ans avant pourquoi 15 ans avant
parce que une voiture roule en moyenne
pendant quinze ans sur les routes
européennes et donc si nous ne mettons
pas fin à la vente de voitures qui ne
sont pas héros émissions de co2 en 2035
cela veut dire que nous ne pouvons pas
respecter l'accord de paris est bon
petit doigt me dit que les constructeurs
automobiles sont un peu inquiet de ce
vote qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui parlement
européen voilà le véritable expert c'est
votre petit doigt parce qu'effectivement
souhaitant notamment français
s'inquiètent parce que d'accord ils ont
déjà vraiment qu'on commençait cette
mutation des constructeurs français
notamment mais c'est pas tout d'en
fabriquer des voitures font encore les
recharger il faudrait des bornes et il
faudrait un million 2035 pour l'instant
il ya soixante mille donc et ils
s'inquiètent un peu et donc le porte
parole de ce qu'on appelle le lobby
automobile
c'est luc chatel valoir il imagine le
pire
le pire serait que l'industrie
automobile et les pouvoirs publics les
états européens et dépenser des
centaines de milliards d'euros et qu'à
la fin il n'y ait pas de consommateurs
au rendez-vous et techniquement nous n'y
arrivons pas qu'ils aient pas de bornes
de recharge penser au week-end de
pentecôte avec les migrations massives
au moment du 14 juillet il faudrait 70
bornes de recharge ultra rapide par
station service sur l'autoroute par nous
en sommes très loin et parle la
pentecôte et encore il a parlé du pont
de l'ascension mais qui
sait manier ce genre d'argument vous
avez compris leur inquiétude en tout cas
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent exactement donc
les huskies aurait voulu en fait ce
qu'on leur laisse une marge de manoeuvre
c'est à dire qu'on leur laisse
construire 10 % de véhicules qu'ils
soient pas 100% électrique soit
thermique par exemple n'est peut-être
avec des moteurs qui consomment beaucoup
moins avec des carburants de synthèse
qui ce qui peut lui beaucoup moins donc
à droite notamment en france et au ppe
dans ta droite européenne on défend des
ce qui paraissait juste mesure on va pas
passer au 100 % électrique on va laisser
10% aux constructeurs pour qu'ils
puissent continuer leurs recherches dans
le délai d'un terminal morano arrive ce
matin chez pascal praud sur ces news ont
dû renvoyer nous on n'est pas trop écolo
on est raisonnable notre présentateur
populiste préféré n'est tombé de celui
d'une force
mais nous dans la proposition que nous
faisons nous voulons une marge
d'ajustement de 10% pour tous les
constructeurs donc vous vous êtes
d'accord pour arrêter aussi de vendre
des véhicules neufs thermique en 2035 et
vous m'invitez pour que je puisse en
place et donc mais j'arrive pas à
comprendre ce que vous dites votre
position c'est que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça un compliqué
aux braves gens qui ne se sont pas
penchés sur le dossier mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on revient à cette
fameuse question qu'on éprouve enfance
aurélie gilet jaune fin du mois contre
fin du monde c'est vrai que même au
niveau européen une partie des
personnels politiques s'inquiètent à
l'idée que ce nouveau règlement est le
même en effet que sur pascal praud c'est
que ça met les gens très en colère et
encore ce n'est que pascal en colère ça
va même s'il ya des millions mais
compliqué mais on va en débattre avec
nos invités merci beaucoup stéphane
blakowski richard wehrli on va d'abord
si vous voulez bien revenir sur ce vote
contre la réforme du marché carbone dont
a parlé stéphane au début de sa
chronique se sont tous les charmes de
l'europe un ce petit jeu des alliances
rendre à vélo improbable au niveau du
parlement européen mais comment comment
ce qu'il faut interpréter ce vote est ce
que est ce que ça veut dire qu'il n'y
aura jamais cette réforme du marché
carbone non je pense que les textes qui
ont été renvoyé en commission vont
revenir mais ce que ça prouve au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est quand même deux
choses qui sont préoccupantes la
première éléments et vous souvenez qu
emmanuel macron et son groupe
renaissance on avait beaucoup parlé à
l'issue des élections européennes de
la grande idée c'est qu'il y aurait
maintenant au parlement européen des
majorités de projet puisque
traditionnellement au parlement européen
vous aviez d'un côté les conservateurs
de l'autre les socialistes étaient les
deux plus grands groupes et c'est eux
qui faisait au fond les décisions
majoritaires les autres était quand même
là un peu en spectateur depuis qu'il ya
eu les élections européennes de 2019 le
groupe renaissance le groupe donc d'
emmanuel macron qui a même donné
maintenant ce nom là à son parti en
france ce groupe et le groupe pivot
c'est donc le groupe qui est supposé
faire la synthèse et permettent les vols
là ça ne marche pas il a tenté un
compromis avec le ppe avec la droite
réactionnaire mais ça ne marche pas donc
on a on a quand même une inquiétude
c'est à dire qu'au fond il suffit
maintenant que que un groupe en
l'occurrence le groupe ppe le groupe
conservateur soit selon les écologistes
travaillé par les lobbys et pour que il
résiste et on voit bien que les autres
composantes ne sont pas capables de se
mettre d'accord pour faire voter ça
c'est inquiétant le deuxième élément je
crois qu'il faut avoir en compte c'est
qu'il y à un pays dont on n'a pas parlé
c'est l'allemagne en allemagne je le
rappelle il ya une coalition au pouvoir
entre les écologistes et les chrétiens
démocrates et les libéraux on pourrait
donc se dire formidable ces trois
groupes politiques quand ils arrivent au
parlement européen je parle des
allemands ils votent ensemble eh bien
non rappel les allemands quand ils sont
au parlement européen ils ne votent pas
comme au bundestag dans leur capital ça
aussi c'est une question alors on va
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui au parlement européen avec
un des acteurs de ce vote en
l'occurrence l'eurodéputé les
républicains françois-xavier bellamy
qu'étant en duplex avec nous depuis le
parlement européen de strasbourg bonsoir
d'abord première question ce qui a été
soumis au vote aujourd'hui on l'a vu un
csc un compromis qui avait été trouvé
entre les libéraux et votre propre
famille politique est ce que vous l'avez
voter vous
bien sûr ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un
compromis qui a été trouvé seulement
avec le groupe riou mais aussi un
compromis qui a été votée dans la
commission de l'industrie à laquelle je
participe et qui inclut aussi les
socialistes ce compromis qui permettait
de mettre en oeuvre le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières tout
en préservant les conditions pour que
l'industrie européenne continue de
travailler continuer d'investir et qu'on
puisse garder donc des emplois une
capacité de production en europe avec
tous les enjeux que ça peut représenter
et aujourd'hui la gauche a décidé alors
qu'elles avaient voté ce texte dans la
commission dont je suis membre elle a
décidé de le saborder au sein du
parlement européens parce que nous
voyons bien qu'il y a derrière
le slogan du climat en réalité une
obsession qui est celle de pénaliser de
fragiliser de saborder l'industrie
européenne au fond on voit bien qu'il ya
toute une partie de la gauche et des
écologistes qui ont renoncé à l'idée de
produire en europe et c c'est l'un des
enjeux majeurs de la taxe carbone c'est
l'un des enjeux majeurs de ce vote
aujourd'hui est un révélateur très
triste révélateur de ce qui constitue
aujourd'hui la priorité de ces de ces
groupes politiques alors ça c'est votre
analyse votre interprétation on va dire
mais la gauche les écologistes aussi eux
explique que si l'on fait capoter ce
vote c'est parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
assez ambitieux on va voir la réaction
de karima delli d'europe écologie les
verts coup de tonnerre au parlement
européen la majorité doit revoir sa
copie et elle s'en félicite
why elle signe avec trois petits biceps
musclée à la fin de son de son tweet
ce compromis pas assez ambitieux selon
les écologistes vous seriez prévoit à
revoir un peu à la hausse ce nom mais ce
texte
on va on va retravailler parce qu'on a
besoin d'une taxe carbone à l'entrée du
marché européen on en a absolument
besoin et pour ce qui nous concerne nous
nous sommes engagés dès la campagne
européenne pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre
ce que nous appelions dans la campagne
une barrière écologique il faut que l'on
fasse en sorte que puisque les
producteurs européens s'acquittent d'une
taxe pour le carbone qu'ils émettent et
bien que ce qui importe en europe ça qui
te aussi de cette même taxe mais voyez
ce qui est tout à fait fascinant dans
cette histoire c'est qu'on voit
aujourd'hui les écologistes qui se
félicite qu'un projet absolument décisif
pour le climat soit abandonnée et
pourquoi s'en félicite il pourquoi se
réjouit-il parce que ce projet était
aussi de nature à préserver la
compétitivité de l'industrie européenne
et finalement c'est ça qui leur pose le
plus de problème c'est le fait que
justement nous ayons trouvé une solution
pour que l'écologie ne rime pas
nécessairement avec la décroissance de
la production que l'écologie ne signifie
pas nécessairement le renoncement à
l'ambition industrielle c'est ça qui
leur pose problème c'est ça qui leur
pose problème au fond et c'est
exactement pour cela que je vois dans ce
vote un moment extrêmement révélateur du
comportement de certains élus qui
prétendent défendre le climat mais qui
me font que s'attaquer à l'économie en
europe alors dernière question ce texte
va donc repartir en commission
parlementaire pour essayer de trouver
une nouvelle base d'accord on peut
espérer un nouveau vote en plénière dans
combien de temps à votre avis c'est une
question de quoi de semaines de mois ou
plus le plus vite possible j'espère le
plus vite possible j'espère oui il faut
que ce soit une question de semaines on
a absolument besoin de voter ce texte on
voit et c'est je crois le plus important
la base de lait pardon il faut partir
que tous les votes qui ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui au parlement sur tous les
aspects de ce texte ont été finalement
une confirmation de la ligne que nous
défendions nous le ppe là la droite
européenne nous avons proposé cet
équilibre global et bien cet équilibre
il a été retenu par une majorité du
parlement et c'est pour cette raison-là
qu'à la fin les socialistes et les
écologistes ont décidé de faire capoter
le texte je crois qu'il faut les ramener
un peu d'humilité puis il faut aussi que
que nos collègues qui par exemple au
rassemblement national où par exemple à
la france insoumise ne cesse de dire qu'
il faut lutter contre une mondialisation
dérégulé une mondialisation sauvage qui
a détruit nos emplois il faut aussi
qu'ils prennent leurs responsabilités
parce que eux aussi ont voté contre la
possibilité de protéger le marché
européen est de retrouver enfin un peu
d'oxygène pour ceux qui veulent produire
dans nos pays je crois que chacun doit
maintenant regarder en face sa
responsabilité et le vote je crois doit
être remis sur la table plus rapidement
possible pour que la taxe carbone à
l'entrée du marché commun qui a fait
l'objet de très nombreux votes
aujourd'hui soit l'occasion d'un vote
final qui soit enfin conclusif merci
beaucoup françois-xavier bellamy d'abord
été donc en direct du parlement européen
à strasbourg
on va s'intéresser à présent à l'autre
votre clé votre clé de la journée cette
fois les eurodéputés n'ont pas calé sur
celui là la fin des voitures essence et
diesel fixes et donc à 2035 plus aucune
voiture neuve ne roulera donc avec du
carburant en 2035 en europe le compromis
doit encore être validé un par les 27
états membres en compte du conseil
européen alors est ce que les français
sont prêts à basculer dans le 100 %
électrique reportage en région
parisienne de léo se et antoine coûtant
ce geste pourrait bien disparaître à
partir de 2035 la pompe à essence
remplacé par des prises électriques
alors la station-service vittel ces
dernières années à massy ces
automobilistes veulent qu'ils croient
2035 ça fait quand même un peu loin si
ça peut être fait un peu plus rapidement
c'est vraiment cool si j'ai les moyens
de le faire je fais demain
voilà après il faut aussi créer les
conditions pour faudrait que l'état m
face au nécessaire parce qu'aujourd'hui
tout est mis en place pour que l'on
puisse continuer à consommer de
l'essence donc il faudrait qu'ils aient
la même chose maintenant pour
l'électrique compliqué pour les petits
budgets mais ce n'est pas le seul frein
absence de bornes de recharge faible
autonomie sans compter que le côté écolo
de l'électrique ne convainc pas tout le
monde pour moi c'est une erreur mackay
travailler dans l'automobile je vous le
dis c'est une erreur
ça va polluer ça plus tard comment on va
les faire comment les recycler batterie
comment on va faire ce qu'on va pouvoir
avoir assez d'électricité pour alimenter
toutes ces voitures et j'espère aussi
il va y avoir des recherches par rapport
à la voiture à hydrogène qui sont aussi
très intéressant et qu'on va pas tout
focaliser aussi sur la voiture
électrique certains sont déjà branchés
c'est le cas d'hervé pour ses trajets du
quotidien il roule à l'électricité et en
est satisfait pas le problème ses
cheveux 30 40 50 ou 60 km peu le charger
apple en boîte à l'endroit que le fait
aujourd'hui en france il existe 60 mille
bornes de recharge l'objectif d'ici à
2025 et de multiplier ce chiffre par
deux pour atteindre 125 1000 points de
chargement pourquoi permettre à hervé de
continuer à rouler avec sa voiture comme
lui de plus en plus de français se
laissent séduire en 2021 une voiture
neuve sur 10 vendus dans l'hexagone
était électrique soit 162 milles
véhicules un chiffre qui a bondi de près
de 50% en un an
richard v rally on voit dans ce
reportage ya plein de bonnes questions
impôts s'est posée par les français
c'est du bon sens mais on sent que ça va
être une vraie révolution le passage au
100 % électrique ça va avoir des
conséquences concrètes sur nos vies oui
est-ce qu'on voit surtout à travers les
entretiens c'est qu'il faut convaincre
les gens et c'est pas seulement vrai en
france il freine les convaincre dans
l'ensemble des pays européens et oh ça
va être encore plus difficile dans des
pays qui n'ont qui sont encore très
sous-équipées sur le plan des bornes
électriques donc moi ce que je retiens
de ce qu'on a vu là bien sûr il ya le
défi technique mais il ya le défi
politique au sens large et l'échec de ce
point de vue là au parlement européen
aujourd'hui quelles qu'en soient les
raisons on a compris tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord c'est un échec politique ça
envoie aux populations le signal
finalement nous parle l'électrique mais
ça va pas vraiment se faire de ce point
de vue là c'est un vrai échec européen
aujourd'hui marie feron ya la question
du coût des voitures électriques est
soulevée dans ce dans ce reportage
regardez ce petit tableau on a regardé
les premiers prix les modèles premier
prix chf et les différents constructeurs
de voitures électriques est en fait ça
revient à près du double d'une voiture à
essence aujourd'hui par exemple la zoé à
32000 euros la clio qui est un modèle
équivalent elle est autour de 16 mille
cinq cents euros dans son dans son
premier prix comment comment on fait
pour que les gens puissent acheter des
voitures électriques aujourd'hui tout le
monde peut pas sortir 30 mille euros
comme ça alors ça c'est sûr aujourd'hui
les voitures électriques sont encore
trop cher mais là je voudrais quand même
souligner qu'elle la décision
d'aujourd'hui est une bonne nouvelle de
ce point de vue parce que c'est en
accélérant la production de véhicules
électriques qu'on va pouvoir commencer à
faire des économies d'échelle et que les
prix vont pouvoir baisser donc il ya une
étude qui est partie est paru fin 2021
publié par bloomberg donc au niveau
européen et il analyse justement
l'évolution des prix donc et il montre
bien que d'ici 2026 et 2027 on a cette
parité prix plus les concevoir arriver à
une parité prix
dont la pré court terme donc voilà donc
d'ici cinq ans alors après on est dans
une situation il faut définir évidemment
que les constructeurs renforcent leurs
objectifs qu'ils accélèrent dès
maintenant parce que c'est quand même
une des faiblesses de la décision qui a
été prise aujourd'hui qui est une très
bonne nouvelle pour le climat parce que
oui ça nous met sur la voie de la
décarbonation total d'ici 2050 ça nous
donne une chance d'y arriver mais il ya
les premières années les années qui sont
devant nous d'ici 2030 où il faut aussi
qu'on sache accélérer très rapidement
donc ça ça va être le défi s'avère pas
suffisamment d'imposer aux constructeurs
vous pensé parce que là il ya quand même
cette échéance on y fait entrer 1035
c'est quelque chose ça donne ça nous
donne un cap à 13 ans il aurait fallu
des étapes et donc il ya des étapes
intermédiaires donc en 2030 il faudra
que 55% conte et 55 % de réduction des
émissions à cette échéance là il ya un
cap aussi en 2025 pour avec un objectif
de 15% ces objectifs là ils sont ils
sont encore un peu trop limité c'est à
dire qu'on voit bien que les
constructeurs ont fait décoller leur
production électrique et puis que ça va
avoir tendance à stagner donc le risque
c'est que ça stagne et donc on espère
aussi que le conseil environnement du 28
juin permettra peut-être de rehausser
ses objectifs et cas précédent 1 chaque
état et la discussion avec les
constructeurs vous avez montré les
constructeurs inquiet constructeurs et
doit effectivement accélérer ses prix
mondial flavien neuvy vous avez rejoint
vous êtes économiste et spécialiste du
secteur automobile vous confirmer cette
perspective de d'avoir des voitures
électriques aux prix des voitures
essence d'ici à 2026 c'est crédible moi
je sais pas répondre à cette question ce
qui fait le coup là le surcoût de la
voiture électrique c'est la batterie
évidemment quand on regarde les courts
du cobalt ou du nickel sur un an ils ont
fait x 2 le lithium x 5 représente
quelque
40 à 50 % du coût de la voiture
électrique c'est pour ça que ça coûte
deux fois plus cher d'ailleurs
donc au fur et à mesure que la demande
mondiales de cobalt va augmenter c'est
tout concentré au congo enfin
l'essentiel des réserves moi je sais pas
jusqu'à quel montant le cours du cobalt
va monter donc c'est un pari
effectivement qui est fait parce que
l'industrie automobile a toujours
fonctionné comme ça c'est une industrie
de masse donc plus on fabrique des
volumes plus on fait des volumes plus on
amortit les coûts et donc on fait
baisser les prix parce que les volumes
augmentent donc c'est le pari de la
voiture électrique de dire plus les
constructeurs automobiles vont fabriquer
de voitures électriques pourrait
beaucoup plus pourront baisser les coûts
unitaires mais ça ça ne marche que si le
cours des matières premières ne
s'envolent pas or pour l'instant on voit
tout mais plutôt tendance à s'envoler
donc qu'il ya quand même une
interrogation par rapport à ça cédric
frère on va regarder un autre tableau
qui est un peu l'état des lieux
aujourd'hui chez les principaux
constructeurs européens quelle est la
part de l'électrique dans les ventes
qu'il réalise aujourd'hui regardez
renault aujourd'hui ça représente 12,1
pour cent de ses ventes peugeot 8 3
hormis tesla qui a 100% évidemment c'est
fiat qui est la plus avancée avec 23 9%
de ses ventes en électriques les
constructeurs vont-ils réussir à monter
en puissance comme ça à 100 % électrique
en aussi peu de temps est ce qu'ils sont
prêts à l'or hélas ou heureusement selon
les points de vue il n'y a plus le choix
rires que aujourd'hui 2035 c'est tout
électrique le petit doigt des ingénieurs
le petit doigt des constructeurs lors a
déjà dit depuis longtemps je pardonnez
moi d'être un peu simple mais les gars
va falloir vraiment y aller donc
aujourd'hui les usines l'ensemble de
l'ingénierie l'ensemble de la recherche
et des flammes développement pardon elle
est axée sur l'électricité donc tout le
monde y va à marche forcée et il ya il
ya aussi un élément sur le prix d'une
voiture c'est la concurrence tout le
monde en ce moment se tirent la bourre
et on verra bien ce qu'il connaît ça
très bien tout le monde a envie de
réussir tout le monde souhaite une voie
d'accès un peu moi quand on entend
carlos tavares on n'a pas l'impression
qu'il soit 100% électrique a révélé des
secrets défense mais il ya effectivement
la posture et discours public parce que
c'est très compliqué une industrie
automobile c'est pas comme de fabriquer
un tee shirt qui cherchent ou ne marche
pas le lendemain vos affaires du bleu
tout va bien aller lassé des industries
extraordinairement lourdes un programme
automobile c'est un milliard d'euros une
voiture c'est un milliard d'euros
c'est des chaînes de ces des chaînes
d'assemblage ccd calcul gigantesque
encore une fois il ya plus le choix il
faut absolument faire de l'électrique
donc tout le monde le sait donc on y va
les ingénieurs ont envie d'être les
premiers ont envie justement de proposer
à l'ensemble du marché un modèle à 25000
euros qui est le prix moyen 9 en france
qu'ils fassent 1000 km d'autonomie pour
pallier tous les problèmes qu'on a vu et
tout a raison de dire zut ça fait pas
d'autonomie comment je vais faire pour
partir en vacances je vais partir le 15
août je vais me retrouver à la station
total ou ou une autre est effectivement
toutes les quatre bornes qui existent
elles seront prises et je vais attendre
deux heures ça tout le monde le sait par
conséquent l'idée c'est de dire allons-y
travaillons très fort sortons les
premiers une voiture à 25000 euros alors
c'est un peu un voeu pieux mais tout le
monde y travaille mais km d'autonomie
mon petit doigt me dit et je connais
bien l'industrie automobile que d'ici
2025 2026
sauf si effectivement il ya des
inconnues majeures sur le prix des
matières premières mais imaginons des
scénarios à l'ailé plus optimiste
possible ce sera possible et ce sera
d'autant plus possible qui ad'autres
d'ingénierie de batteries qui sont les
batteries solide qui ne tiennent pas
compte de linge et de 2,2 de la
technologie d'aujourd'hui qui nous
promettent ce genre de choses une bonne
nouvelle faisons que non mais c'est
parce que effectivement on peut tous s
agiter dire c'est là c'est la fin des
haricots moi je suis optimiste il ya
quand même fait venir de nos vies la
question aussi de ba2 des emplois dans
l'automobile en france va falloir
reconvertir beaucoup de gens il va y
avoir une casse sociale importante
comment comment ça peut se faire ça
parce que les constructeurs automobiles
s'adapteront effectivement c'est ils ont
déjà pris ils ont compris ils sont en
train de te reconvertir complètement
leurs hôtes ils recherchent de
production donc ils ont ils ont ils
anticipent un petit peu là où ce sera
plus compliqué c'est clairement sur les
équipementiers les petits équipementiers
ce qui fabrique des pièces pour les
moteurs c'est pas des grosses équipes
manquent et des multinationales c'est
des fonderies et là on va pas
transformer une fonderie en fabrique de
cellules pour les les batteries
électriques donc là il ya les gars alors
ça aussi c'est un point dont on parle
pas beaucoup mais évidemment la voiture
électrique alors tant mieux pour les
automobilistes mais il ya plus de
courroie de distribution plus de vidange
plus de boîte de vitesses et donc les
mécaniciens qui travaillent sur
l'ensemble du territoire national c'est
des emplois qui sont pas délocalisables
cela ne va pas externaliser je sais pas
où bah oui et très clairement il y aura
moins besoin de ces emplois à moyen long
terme et je rajoute un point juste en 10
secondes on ouvre quand même en grand
les portes aux constructeurs chinois qui
sont très bons ils ont 20 ans d'avancé
donc ça favorise aussi la concurrence
chinoise tension ils sont très forts ils
font des bonnes voitures et moins cher
il ya un petit truc sur la maintenance
est vrai que les cours maintenant sous
le coup de la révision va évidemment
être beaucoup plus faible parce qu'il ya
plus de vidange et tout ça certains
disaient plus que les essuie glaces en
fait on s'est aperçu et les premiers
retours les voitures électriques et
accélère beaucoup plus fort même la
moindre d'une voiture électrique
aujourd'hui elle accélère plus fort
qu'une gt il ya dix à vingt ans et on
s'est aperçu qu'en fait que les pneus
s'usent et davantage et ya des premiers
retours ou les jours 10 mais en fait on
va changer plus de pneus ok il ya
d'autres courent plus pour commencer à
faire super on va changer des pneus oui
oui peut-être non juste sur ce plan pour
préciser pour qu'on avance dans le débat
c'est la difficulté c'est exactement ce
que vous disiez c'est à dire que la taxe
carbone va avec et c'est pas hasard si
les textes étaient présentées en même
temps aujourd'hui
20 avec la garonne aux frontières la
grille on regarde nos frontières va avec
l'interdiction des véhicules thermiques
après 2035 or là on en a qu'un pan c'est
en ça que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
parce que si vous voulez expliquer aux
gens que c'est un tout encore
faudrait-il le voter comme un tout et on
confondre est il que tous les partis
politiques principaux parlement européen
soit d'accord or ils ne le sont pas
c'est quand même un mauvais signal même
si l'un des textes a été votée marie
feron pour faire rouler des voitures
100% électriques il faut de
l'électricité
non mais ma question et les services
qu'on a les moyens de produire
suffisamment d'électricité en france
aujourd'hui pour faire rouler toutes ces
voitures électriques parce qu'on voit
que c'est un peu compliqué aujourd'hui
avec nos centrales nucléaires
vieillissantes alors c'est effectivement
une question qui est très régulièrement
posée rte donc le transporteur
d'électricité en france a fait des
scénarios ça fait plusieurs années que
le travail a débuté et ça a été publié à
l'automne oui il ya aujourd'hui un
système électrique en france qui nous
permet d'envisager de faire rouler
plusieurs millions de véhicules d'ici
2100 veut dire augmenter nos capacités
de production comme ça en claquant des
doigts parce que il aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui pour pour que ce soit
compatible avec notre système électrique
il faut aussi que par ailleurs on fasse
des économies d'énergie ça passe par des
économies et gros défi sur la transition
énergétique pour réduire le premier
poste de dépense énergétique et le
chauffage chez nous quand même il ya
également du député défi dans
l'industrie pour réduire la consommation
d'électricité
et puis il ya aussi fait que un véhicule
électrique on va pas pouvoir se
permettre d'avoir des véhicules qui
consomment à des niveaux trop élevés
donc ce que souligne rte aussi dans ses
scénarios c'est que si on veut arriver à
atteindre nos objectifs climat parce que
chaque fois qu'on aimait l'électricité
ya en plus des émissions de co2 eh bien
il va falloir qu'on est des véhicules
qu'ils soient aussi plus performant et
qu'on maîtrise l'évolution des batteries
tout le monde n'a pas besoin d'avoir des
batteries de 1000 kilomètres qui vont
jusqu'à 1000 kilomètres donc ça va
rassurer une certaine partie de des gens
qui en ont besoin et ça ça permettra
sûrement de massifier le marché mais ce
qu'il faut voir aussi c'est qu'à un
moment donné va falloir qu'on est des
véhicules qui soit adaptée à nos besoins
je rappelle qu'en moyenne on fait moins
de 50 kilomètres par jour chacun donc
finalement on pourrait avoir aussi des
véhicules plus petits avec moins de
matières premières et qui consomment
moins d'électricité
alors il ya une autre question qui est
celle de la recharge des véhicules les
bornes on a vu dans le reportage en a
que 60 mille aujourd'hui en france
abou cédric fréhaut je vous pose la
question quel est l'objectif 100000
bornes oui il va en falloir combien des
bornes 35 pour recharger nos voitures
qui va payer parce que c'est un
investissement est ce que c'est un
investissement du secteur privé est ce
que les pouvoirs publics vont y
participer est-ce que lui en aura en
dehors du secteur autoroutier sur tous
les réseaux secondaires en vérité je ne
sais pas qui est capable de répondre on
va tous apprendre en marchant il ya
quelqu'un qui a pris le taureau par les
cornes qui s'appelle elon musk qui quand
il a dix ans d'avancé même 15 ans s'est
dit moi j'ai proposé une voiture
électrique qui va essayer de remplacer
et se substituer une voiture thermique
les bornes c'est un problème il y en a
pas bon ben je prends toi ma charge je
vais les je vais justement faire en
sorte d'avoir mon propre réseau de
bornes comme ça je rassurais les
premiers acheteurs aujourd'hui il a une
avance considérable quand l'industrie
allemande l'industrie française s'est
dit zut effectivement il faut qu'on
l'électrique ça y est il faut qu'on y
aille bon bah ouais les bornes comment
on va faire qui va payer
on est là dedans alors il ya des
consortiums et les constructeurs
allemands qui se sont associés notamment
le programme unity est aujourd'hui
chacun sait dire notamment les allemands
sont dit ok super on met de l'argent
chez you need is cellules in pti ça
n'avance pas comme on voudrait certains
constructeurs allemands sont dits
notamment audi s'est dit non non moi je
vais faire comme elon musk je vais avoir
mes propres mais probant de recharge
vous allez trop lentement ensuite il ya
des réflexions tout bête quand on arrive
à une borne les cartes bleues je suis et
c'est mon métier c'est d'essayer toutes
les voitures vous arriver le soir 7 au
mois de novembre et 18 heures vous
n'êtes pas sous le auvent super chouette
de la station nickel vous êtes souvent
relégués à 100 m voilà vous êtes pas la
bonne carte le lampadaire qui ne l'ont
pas dire qu'il existe comme ça vous
éclaire mal l'écran pour que vous
puissiez badges et ça devient c'est
l'enfer alors ça c'est l'enfer
aujourd'hui mais tout le monde en a pris
conscience est là j'aimerais vous
apporter une réponse définitive à cette
à cette question la seule certitude
c'est que chaque constructeur en a
pleinement confiance qui connaissent
l'urgence et que s'ils souhaitent
effectivement que l'ensemble des clients
puissent être convaincu il faut mettre
des bornes donc ça serait au
constructeur d'investir là dedans en
fait on annonce 100000 bornes c'était
100 mille bornes d'ici fin 2020 on en a
soixante mille et ça fait très longtemps
qu'on amasse des grands projets comme ça
mais tout le monde se renvoie la balle
parce que les constructeurs considèrent
que c'est pas forcément à eux de le
faire les pétroliers en met un peu sur
leurs stations mais c'est pas ça qui va
résoudre le problème il en faut plus les
collectivités territoriales n'ont pas
forcément l'argent nécessaire pour le
faire où l on met de temps et l'europe
parce que c'est l'europe qui imposerait
je pense que franchement c'est un sujet
majeur parce que psychologiquement les
gens ont besoin de voir ces bornes de
recharge dans l'espace public pour pour
être rassurés après pour revenir sur la
question de l'électricité on pourra
aussi certainement recharger les
voitures à des moments à des heures
creuses sera capable de faire de la
programmation pour pas prendre sur le
réseau au moment où tout le monde allume
son radiateur à la maison donc de ce
côté là je pense qu'il ya des progrès
techniques fait et puis un mot aussi
puisqu'on parle d'électricité de
recharge est quand même la question de
parce que c'est présenté comme une
opération pour la neutralité carbone
objectif 2050 ok mais l'électricité pour
qu'elle soit un peu décarbonés et tous
les pays d'europe ne sont pas au même
niveau de ce point de vue là sion saison
de la pologne attend dès la fin du débat
posé la question excusez moi marie feron
est ce que est ce qu'on est sûr que ce
soit vraiment plus écolo l'électricité
parce qu'il faut produire cette
électricité de façon décarbonée il faut
extraire des terres rares et là on sait
qu'il ya un problème quand même il faut
recycler les batteries on sait pas
vraiment faire priori en tout cas il ya
on sait pas totalement faire est ce que
tous ces points négatifs ont été mis
dans la balance avantage bénin bénéfices
quand tous ces points là ils sont
légitimes parce qu'il faut qu'on se pose
ces questions là et qu'on ne peut pas
laisser le doute planer sur quoi que ce
soit simplement aujourd'hui une voiture
électrique c'est trois à cinq fois moins
de gaz à effet de serre sur l'ensemble
du cycle de vie c'est à dire sur une
maison près en premier la production de
l'extraction jusqu'à la fin de vie
ces trois à cinq fois moins de gaz à
effet de serre aujourd'hui si on ne
prend la fin de vie vous l'estimez ou la
durée de vie d'une voiture électrique
parce que la batterie
la batterie aujourd'hui on n'a pas
encore suffisamment de retours mais les
retours qu'on a sont déjà positif une
batterie ça une durée de vie estimée de
10 ans
donc après en fonction de l'usagé qu'on
peut avoir la durée de vie peut être pu
être un peu réduite mais aujourd'hui
quand on a cet atout climat parce que
c'est pas rien de réduire les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de trop de d'un
facteur 3 à 5 avec le défi qui est
devant nous sur la décarbonation de
transport le giec le dit lui même le
passage à l'électrique c'est un des
aspects incontournables des politiques
qu'on a amené aujourd'hui donc oui la
voiture électrique elle est plus prompt
sur la question du juste du recyclage et
des terres rares je rappelle que
effectivement aujourd'hui notre problème
majeur en europe c'est qu'on est
dépendant des ressources minérales
extérieur donc il ya aussi tout un
programme tel que l'alliance pour les
batteries qui consiste à localiser la
production en europe et des programmes
de r&d qui sont lancés pour avoir des
batteries qui consomme nettement moins
de ressources minérales il ya d'ailleurs
des choses assez intéressantes pour
qu'on puisse se passer de cobalt mine de
rien d'ici après voilà pour pouvoir
recycler c'est pas c'est pas une
industrie qui se met en place en deux
ans c'est une industrie qui va demander
5 ans 10 ans 15 ans mais les déchets de
demain seront la mine aussi de demain
donc ce qu'il faut espérer c'est à voir
aussi
des volumes de batteries suffisant pour
le pouvoir les recycler de monde juste
le mot de la fin pour vont réserver à 10
et où l'un pour vous y croyez c'est oui
cet objectif affiché comme ça vous y
croyez oui mais à la condition qu'il y
ait un arsenal législatif qui avance en
même temps on ne pourra pas avoir les
voitures la généralisation des voitures
électriques si on n'a pas la taxe
carbone aux frontières pour se protéger
de la concurrence chinoise si on n'a pas
d'autres mesures c'est ça qui est
important c'est quand même ça
l'enseignement d'aujourd'hui je rappelle
juste un vote qui a eu lieu cette
semaine au parlement européen parce
qu'il va être parlant c'est seulement
cette semaine au parlement européen qui
a été voté le chargeur de délaisser l
uimm du monde attend depuis combien de
temps et encore c'est pas pour tout de
suite
quand même là le message mérite
réflexion merci beaucoup à tous d'être
venus sur le plateau de cp pour ce ce
grand décryptage on passe à notre grand
témoin à présent françois-xavier ménages
grand reporter à tf1 et co auteur avec
ava djamshidi d'un livre consacré à
sarah knafo et au rôle clé que cette
jeune femme à jouer dans la campagne
présidentielle d'eric zemmour le
portrait de notre invité est signée marc
premier
si on vous invite françois xavier ménage
c'est pour parler d'une femme ô combien
intrigante lumière sur sarah knafo chef
d'orchestre de la campagne d'eric
zemmour eric zemmour qui est sarah knafo
ma collaboratrice
ma compagne il n'y aurait pas eu de
campagne conservateur françois-xavier
ménage vous êtes journaliste de vous
nous retenons votre passage sur m6 à la
présentation de capital mais votre adn
c'est le terrain d'abord grand reporter
pour bfmtv voulez aujourd'hui pour tf1
lci des événements qui bouscule le monde
vous y êtes révolutions du printemps
arabe fukushima et dernièrement la
guerre en ukraine je vais parler
personnellement je vais enlever la
petite casquette de journaliste un
instant mais moi j'ai deux filles et
c'est vrai que quand on était à 200
kilomètres de marioupol et et qu'on a vu
dans un hôpital des enfants qui étaient
entre la vie et la mort qui avait entre
je vais essayer de pas chialer entre 3
et 14 ans dans votre dernier livre
coécrit avec ava djamshidi vous avez
enquêté durant six mois sur la
conseillère de l'ombre et compagne du
trublion eric zemmour l'histoire secrète
d'un candidat sous influence eric
zemmour dont on n'imaginait qu'ils
avaient une indépendance si je puis dire
intellectuelle est en fait en porosité
intégrale avec elle c'est un duo un duo
pour un tango bien rôdé sur le front des
idées sarah knafo une énarque décrite
comme brillante et manipulatrice à
seulement 28 ans elle devient la
directrice de campagne d'eric zemmour et
en bon stratège politique elle surveille
tous les mécanismes de la machine
électorale valide les moindres détails
du trombinoscope de l'équipe de campagne
au tempo des meetings à reconquête son
surnom ses patronnes sarah knafo c'est
une personnalité qui recèle énormément
d'ambiguïté c'est quelqu'un qui est
extrêmement moderne sur la forme qui a
su fabrique électoralement un candidat
etc à la fois totalement traditionaliste
dans ses idées ambitions vertigineuse
plébiscité dans son camp pour son
influence sarah knafo a bousculé le
récit de la présidentielle malgré
l'échec mais où s'arrêtera-t-elle qu'en
pensez-vous françois-xavier ménage vous
qui l'avez suivi côtoyé peut-elle avoir
un destin politique député ministre et
pourquoi pas président de la république
à vous la parole
bonsoir françois xavier bonsoir vous
aborder cette question qui est posée
dans le livre vous y croyez vous à une
ambition présidentielle personnelle de
sara knafo la question c'est d'abord si
elle et son entourage y croit et je vais
vous donner juste une scène parce
qu'évidemment a pas faire de la
politique fiction mais on est quelques
jours après le premier tour des fêtes
donc dans le camp d'eric zemmour bien
sûr et c'est seulement à ce moment là
qu'on a vus nous sarah knafo pour lui
poser quelques questions précises sur ce
livre on avait vu 80 personnes autour
d'elle avant un mais et là on a vu à
saint germain pour tout vous dire
plusieurs personnes s'arrêter dans la
rue dont une qui a dit continuez madame
continuez continuez elle pensait sarah
knafo que c'était d'eric zemmour que
parler ces dames a dit non non vous vous
continuez un présidence présidence et
elle est rien c'était pas la première
fois qu'on lui disait ça nous a dit
d'ailleurs sarah knafo qui s'est bien
gardé de répondre davantage mais dans
son entourage tout le monde dit une
chose et d'ailleurs elle même a prononcé
cette phrase je ne finirai pas comme
marie-france garaud qui était il ya peu
de temps encore son modèle donc
sous-entendu un moment il y aura ce
passage de l'ombre vers la lumière la
lumière mais on n'y est pas encore
vous dites aussi dans ce livre elle a
fabriqué un objet électoral inédit qui a
bouleversé les équilibres politiques de
la campagne
comment est-ce que vous définiriez-vous
cet objet qu'elle a façonné qu'est-ce
qu'elle a mis elle est où sa marque à
elle alors le polémiste existait avant
elle le journaliste du figaro existait
avant elle en revanche son envie de
présidentielle si on interroge son
entourage commencer par philippe de
villiers tout le monde nous dit qu des
limiers des années 2010 il avait une
petite envie sauf que elle et a fait que
la petite envie se transforme en
chantier et ça veut donc dire qu'elle a
créée autour d'eric zemmour des cercles
concentriques de personnes et de
personnalités de premier plan en tout
cas dans dans le dans le champ
idéologique qui est le sien qui allait
aider et elle a recruté un an et demi
avant que le candidat ne soit vraiment
candidat donc elle lui a offert les
moyens de ses ambitions mais est-ce
qu'elle a nourri son ambition bien sûr
elle a nourri son ambition elle a nourri
aussi ses discours et ce que l'on
raconte dans le livre avec ava djamshidi
que ça lui est bien c'est notamment une
scène à londres quelques jours avant
qu'il ne soit ce que vous l'avez côtoyé
dans le cadre de ces documentaires que
vous avez réalisés pendant la campagne
présidentielle et fort j'en ai fait
quatre mois et la première fois que je
rencontre sarah cnaf on est donc à
londres quelques jours avant que eric
zemmour ne soit officiellement candidat
c'est un secret de polichinelle et on
assiste à la fabrication d'un discours
il doit rencontrer plusieurs centaines
de français qui habite à londres et la
eric zemmour démarre quelques notes
qu'il avait marqué sur son téléphone et
il commence des références historiques
et elle le couple au bout de trois
minutes ils sont pour ainsi dire seuls
dans la pièce et lui dit non trop de
références historiques tu vas commencer
avec la guerre du nord dit la gare du
nord mais parce que la gare du nord les
français de londres qui viennent en
france quand il arrive à paris le grand
remplacement ça démarre gare du nord ce
sont les mots de sarah knafo bien sûr et
cet argument là sera repris mot pour mot
par eric zemmour une demi heure plus
tard donc on a avec cette scène khider
n'aura jamais été rediffusé ensuite
enfin pardon filmé par d'autres mais ça
montre est quelque chose d'assez
incroyable à savoir que effectivement le
discours s'est créé toujours à quatre
mains et que c'est un duo qui a fait
campagne c'est un duo qui se présentait
ça n'était pas eric zemmour tout seul
vous raconter aussi qu'avant eric
zemmour elle a porté la campagne
présidentielle d'un autre candidat en
2016 henri guaino campagne qui a échoué
un ça donne quand même un peu
l'impression d'une forme d'obsession
chez elle comme si elle tenait à tous
prix apporter un homme ou une femme
peut-être à la présidence de la
république pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il ya
derrière ça il ya cette envie
dit elle que ces idées deviennent
dominante sauf que là aussi et c'est
pour ça que ce livre je pense dit
quelque chose de la politique en 2022
c'est qu' il décrit des idées une
radicalité à droite qui avait pas avant
et avec henri guaino elle le lance entre
guillemets l'aide à se lancer pour la
présidentielle elle crée un groupe les
jeunes avec guaino comme il y aura
ensuite les jeunes avec zemmour et ce
modèle là elle applique avec donc henri
guaino ça ne marche pas et ensuite il y
aura une rupture idéologique entre les
deux parce qu'henri guaino dix mois les
questions identitaires situent les
sépare des questions sociales ça ne
marche pas c'est pas possible et la
rupture se fait là parce que sarah knafo
pense que l' identitaire les questions
identitaires et bien c'est quelque chose
de fondamental et ça peut faire
renverser une partie de l'opinion la
question est de savoir de quelle opinion
par bien sûr alors vous évoquez aussi un
drame familial qui a profondément marqué
l'enfance de sarah knafo une agression
dont sa mère a été victime alors qu'elle
était enceinte cela a eu pour
conséquence un handicap lourd pour le
petit frère de sarah knafo est-ce que ce
drame a pu jouer un rôle dans la
construction politique idéologique alors
sarah knafo et je pense trop subtil pour
dire et on lui a posé la question donc
pour dire que ça découle évidemment
directement de de ce fait divers atroce
bien sûr qui as qu en fait l'auteur de
des faits n'a jamais été interpellés
jamais condamné son frère qui était donc
handicapés à l'issue de cette agression
dont a été victime sa maman sous frère
est décédé ensuite quand il avait autour
de 20 ans donc ça a eu un impact
considérable dans la famille sarah knafo
ne s'épanche pas sur cette question et
elle est trop subtile je pense pour dire
qu'ensuite ça a eu un impact
considérable sur son son socle
idéologique politique mais il est
certain que ça a eu effectivement eu des
conséquences maintenant elle dit elle
même et c'est une phrase qui est très
troublante elle dit mais on
on nous considère comme étant la
minorité nous qui sommes plutôt radicaux
entre guillemets et cette minorité je
considère que c'est de moins en moins
vrai excès de moins en moins le cas donc
vous voyez que derrière ses idéaux il ya
l'idée de se compter et c'est aussi pour
ça que la présidentielle a été fait à
deux elle eric zemmour s'était en vérité
de savoir jusqu'à quel point ses idées
aujourd'hui peuvent être reportés non
pas par des jeunes quand je dis des
jeunes séparer xénon c'est elle et son
premier cercle ce sont des jeunes ils
ont la vingtaine ils ont la trentaine
pour certains et ils veulent faire
entendre ils veulent démontrer que l'on
peut être jeune radical est cool c'est
en tout cas ce triptyque là qui a été
mise en scène est mise en images dans
cette campagne il ya aussi un
qualificatif que vous utilisez dans le
titre de votre livre l'intrigante sarah
knafo au fil des pages on découvre
qu'elle a un talent formidable pour se
faire un carnet d adresses en quelque
sorte pour obtenir les conseils du
berger dream par exemple ou de jacques
attali quand elle prépare les concours
de l'ena c'est quoi sa technique comment
est-ce qu'elle s'y prend c'est vrai que
selon toute vraisemblance on connaît peu
d'étudiants même à sciences po qui ont
le droit d'avoir du bachotage pour
réviser l'ena avec effectivement hubert
védrine jacques attali ou henri guaino
qui vous aide pour réviser les questions
donc déjà c'est en quelque sorte un
petit exploit elle s'est bien gardé de
dire comment elle faisait à l'époque
mais ça a créé une sorte de petite
légende notamment à sciences po et dans
son entourage et la méthode et c'est ce
que l'on montre dans notre enquête c'est
que elle a participé à une association
qui était plutôt souverainiste et que à
chaque invité dont ceux que je viens de
citer eh bien elle prenait soin de les
voir avant de prendre des cafés avec de
discuter de tisser des liens qui
devenait ensuite des liens
professionnels assez fort et par la
suite eh bien henri cochet elle arrivait
à obtenir d'autres grands noms qui
devenait en quelque sorte son réseau
partant entre guillemets n'ont pas de
rien n'est pas avec la même chance que
d'autres donc il ya une ascension
sociale on dirait du maupassant on
dirait presque une belle me et set à
sens sociaux social et politique je
pense que là encore elle dit quelque
chose de la france de 2022 beaucoup
d'hommes et de femmes politiques sont un
peu dans un rapport de séduction avec
les gens là en ce qui concerne saraka
faut vous vous parlez plutôt de son
intelligence sociale c'est quoi c'est ce
dont pour nouer des relations avec les
gens c'est ça ce que valent elles
arrivent quand même en stage quand elle
est à l'ena à pau la préfecture de pau
et elle trouve le moyen alors qu'elle
est dans l'avion qu'elle n'a pas encore
posé sa valise à pau de nouer des
contacts avec jean lassalle dans l'avion
comme par hasard ils sont pas loin et
elle s'assoit à côté de lui calcul au
rendez vous pour que dans les prochaines
semaines elle le voit appuyez ensuite
elle essaiera de faire la même chose
avec françois bayrou à pau et puis le
préfet et bien elle va se le mettre dans
la poche au point qu'ils deviennent
ensuite l'un des personnages essentiels
de la campagne présidentielle d'eric
zemmour donc elle a ce talent de savoir
s'imposer avec une arme par ailleurs et
là on parle pas d'idéologie caisson
sourire parce qu'en toute circonstance
même quand les choses vont mal elle
garde un sourire du moins de façade qui
effectivement en quelque sorte une
partie de 2 de sa stratégie parce que
c'est une femme qui sait utiliser des
stratégies politiques pour l'arrivée
arias la relation politique qui est une
eric zemmour à sarko et puis on a
découvert pendant la campagne cette
relation amoureuse aussi est ce que
cette relation amoureuse ne fausse pas
leurs relations politiques ce n'est pas
un risque alors que ça donne des
ateliers repas dont vous vous lui
demandez quel est votre personnage
historique préférez vous répond eric
zemmour ça vous dirait du marketing de
mauvaises écoles de commerce est oui ça
veut dire maintenant ce qui est certain
aussi c'est que les deux se les deux
s'alimentent aujourd'hui après nous on
n'a pas fait un l'ifpi paul pour savoir
quel était leur vie de couple est ce que
ça donnerait dans dix ans une fois de
plus c'est vraiment pas ce qui nous
intéressait avec havas en revanche on
voit que cette dualité elle est présente
partout elle est présente dans les
meetings évidemment pour écrire des
discours je voulais dit mais elle est
aussi présente dans ce long récit qui
s'écrit depuis deux ans entre eux deux
et là d'une certaine manière c'est rare
pour ne pas dire rarissime en politique
ils sont au même niveau et à certains
moments elle est même plus présentes
elle a plus les mains sur le volant que
eric zemmour lui-même d'un mot l'échec
de la présidentielle peut-il fragiliser
leurs relations politiques
évidemment bien malin celui qui pourra
répondre ce que juste certain c'est
qu'ils ont compris qu'avec la guerre en
ukraine ça sentait mauvais dès le 24
février et ensuite pour le reste leurs
ambitions sont liés mais pas que et je
pense on en revient à ce qu'on s'est dit
au début que à un moment sarah knafo
sera très tenté par l'idée d'une
aventure politique qui la concerne elle
on n'y est pas encore il ya trop de
personnes pourront avoir parlé autour
d'elle pour qu'à un moment on ne se pose
pas des questions suivra ça de près
merci beaucoup françois-xavier ménages
rappelle donc le titre de votre ouvrage
l'intrigante sarah knafo paru chez
robert laffont
merci merci et vous restez avec nous
placent à nouveau a franchi à présent
avec nous ce soir elsa monde un gars qui
va nous raconter un peu l'ambiance qui
est un peu morose au sein de la majorité
à quelques jours du premier tour des
élections législatives
emmanuel ducrocq qui s'est penché sur la
hausse à venir des tarifs dans les
cantines scolaires 8 août augmentant ce
moment et ce n'est pas fini enfin
emmanuel macron at il commis une erreur
en disant qu'il ne faut pas humilier la
russie le point de vue à venir de
vincent hugeux dans un instant
elle a comme chaque soir aux chroniques
donc les 577 sur les élections
législatives premier tour dimanche on le
rappelle assis sur lcp évidemment ce
soir vous nous parler d' emmanuel macron
qui était à clichy-sous-bois aujourd'hui
sera à gaillac dans le tarn demain on al
impression un peu qu'il accélère dans la
dernière ligne droite oui ce sont deux
déplacements bienvenue pour ses troupes
le président la république était donc à
clichy sous bois pour parler sport et
jeunesse mais il a évidemment aussi
parlé de la campagne un président qui
montent au créneau il a critiqué la
nuque il s'est aussi montré plutôt
confiant regarder ce qu'il a déclaré je
pense que les françaises et les français
sauront donner une majorité au projet
que je porte un optimisme et bien qui
tranche un peu avec une certaine
fébrilité dans la majorité à quelques
jours du premier tour ils voient pas
d'un très bon oeil les sondages qui leur
donne pas forcément une majorité absolue
ici à l'assemblée certaines voix
critiquent un peu en off et bien une
stratégie de campagne un petit peu
flottante on est dans le flou permanent
surtout se désole un candidat et des
membres de la majorité bien ils
réclamaient une prise de parole forte
claire d' emmanuel macron
une parole type valéry giscard d'estaing
à verdun le doubs alors je vois dire
tout c'est de quoi vous parlez mais ce
que pouvaient quand même me rafraîchir
apple mais moi c'était en 1978 dont vous
avez une bonne et ce que je crois que
vous étiez pas encore nés mais en
soixante dix huit mais peut-être un peu
plus tard que vous aviez peut-être
quelques semaines alors valéry giscard
d'estaing avait été élu faisait campagne
pour les élections législatives
et il a lancé un appel clair aux
électeurs écouter
légère française et légères français le
moment s'approche
où vous allez faire un choix capital
pour l'avenir de notre pays
mais aussi un choix capital pour vous
je suis venu vous demander
de faire le bon choix pour la france il
a mis dedans jeu et il fallait selon
certains membres de la majorité
justement cette parole perd presque
performative 1 pour appeler à la
mobilisation des troupes alors pas sûr
que les attentes de ses membres de la
majorité soit complètement rempli par le
président de la république mais il lui
reste le tarn demain alors il ya un peu
d'inquiétude dans la majorité mais
étonnamment il ya plutôt de la sérénité
du côté des républicains bah oui c'était
hier leur dernier conseil stratégique
avant le premier tour il était tout
sourire et ils étaient 11 pour
l'occasion pour la conférence de presse
et ils ont affiché une certaine
confiance écouter christian jacob c'est
le président du parti je pense que la
semaine prochaine mais surtout dans
quinze jours on créera la surprise parce
que justement on est capable
de représenter nos territoires c'est
500c 577 morceau de france qui vont
choisir le candidat l'élu qui va les
représenter pendant cinq ans et pendant
ces cinq ans on n'a pas besoin d'avoir
des gens qui veulent la révolution
permanente et bloquer le pays pour tous
et on n'a pas besoin de refaire un
quinquennat qui sert à rien et c'est là
que nous ferons la différence et je
pense que nous allons créer la surprise
créé la surprise dans verra s'ils
gardent le sourire voilà dimanche soir à
suivre sur lcp soirée spéciale merci
beaucoup elsa on passe avoue emmanuel
ducrocq on va parler ce soir du prix des
cantines scolaires avec cet article du
parisien c'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle puisque les factures vont
augmenter de 7 à 8% comment est-ce que
ça s'explique moi ça c'est en tout cas
ce que demandent les prestataires des
cantines scolaires alors ces cantines
scolaires c'est un point crucial de
l'alimentation de nos enfants chaque
année on parle de 1,2 milliard de repas
qui sont servis de la maternelle au
lycée donc c'est vraiment pas rien et
toutes les fournitures alimentaires sont
en train de se renchérir les légumes la
viande les laitages les céréales
absolument tout hausse ainsi que le
carburant ainsi que les emballages bref
c'est toute la chaîne de production de
ce qu'on met dans les assiettes qui
coûte plus cher et selon les
professionnels si l'inflation pour
l'instant c'est à peu près 4 8% sur
l'alimentation ça sera probablement 15%
d'ici à l'été donc ça veut dire que les
prix se renchérissent parce que les
salaires aussi se renchérissent ils
représentent 60% du coût d'un repas de
cantine en france les fournitures c'est
-2% non tout ça voilà ça fait cette
enveloppe qui explose et qui va payer
alors selon les endroits selon les âges
avant la hausse un repas de cantine
scolaire ça coûtait entre 5 euros 50 et
15 euros la moyenne c'est 7% et selon
les spécialistes il est difficile de
descendre en dessous de ça pour avoir
quelque chose de correct alors on a deux
solutions soit ce sont les collectivités
qui paye tout ou partie de la hausse les
maires pour les maternelles
département pour les collèges les
régions pour les lycées soit ce sont les
familles or pour beaucoup de familles la
cantine c'est extrêmement cher c'est
extrêmement lourd et pourtant c'est
capital parce qu'on avait vu pendant le
confinement à quel point les enfants
modeste étaient affectés par la
fermeture des cantines alors 80 % des
villes depuis dix mille habitants ont
des tarifs sociaux mais la plupart des
villes la moitié en france n'ont pas
donc voilà c'est un point énorme qui va
reposer sur les épaules des familles
est-ce qu'on a des marges de manoeuvre
il n'y a pas beaucoup parce que la
composition d'un menu deux camps de
cantine c'est un équilibre il ya des
recommandations extrêmement précis sur
les compositions sur les grammages on
peut difficilement en sortir et puis
vous savez les nouvelles recommandations
issues de la loi et galim disent que
maintenant il faut la moitié des
produits qu'ils soient issus de signes
de qualité locaux et bio est donc tout
ça et bien ça renchérit la facture et
donc les collectivités territoriales ne
vont pas avoir 8000 choix soit ils vont
mettre la main à la poche et elles vont
donc subventionner un petit peu plus
alors après c'est les grands travaux
l'autre solution c'est de revoir le
système de a à z de ne plus forcément
passer par un prestataire mais de revoir
tout le coût des approvisionnements en
passant en direct en refaisant de la
cuisine mais ça ça veut dire que le coût
du travail se renchérit on peut
mutualiser les coûts avec les ehpad avec
les hôpitaux dans certains endroits mais
tout ça tout ça c'est énormément
énormément de travail ça ne se fait pas
en un claquement de doigts pas en
quelques mois mais tout ça c'est capital
c'est capital pour les enfants c'est un
choix politique la cantine c'est quand
l'économie et la politique rencontre
vraiment le quotidien dans l'assiette
des enfants c'est un choix d'égalité
sociale pour les plus jeunes et donc ça
mérite vraiment qu'on y réfléchisse
quant aux citoyens ils faut qu'ils
sachent quand ils volent tu votes pour
les élections locales ça sert aussi à ça
et on va voir j'imagine que ça va ce
sujet un va s'inviter dans le débat
public dans les semaines qui viennent
merci beaucoup emmanuel ducron passe
avoue vincent hugeux bonsoir vous
souhaitiez revenir sur cette petite
phrase qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre un prononcé par emmanuel macron
qui a expliqué qu'il ne fallait pas
humilier la russie une petite phrase qui
passe mal dans une bonne partie de
l'europe c'est le moins qu'on puisse en
dire sur l'échiquier planétaire le
second mandat d'emmanuel macron commence
par une énigme pourquoi diable le
sortant réélu nous serine t'il qu'il ne
faut un millier la russie ni poutine une
antienne entonnait pour la énième fois
samedi au détour d'une interview fleuve
accordée à la presse régionale ce
faisant notre jupiter nationale comme
est à mon sens une double erreur lexical
est tactique le choix des mots d'abord
le concept d' humiliations appartient au
registre de la psychologie de l'affect
du sentiment or l'enjeu s'agissant de
l'agression militaire contre l'ukraine
n'est pas d'épargné au tsar moscovite je
ne sais quel mortification mais de le
contraindre tout et anti six rapports de
force à renoncer à ses fantasmes
impériaux croyez vous vraiment qu en
ménageant son ego on lui attendre et le
cuir alors vous parlez aussi d'une faute
tactique oui la tactique ensuite parce
que macron brouille ainsi le message de
fermeté occidental risque d'éveiller le
soupçon de kharkiv à varsovie et de
bucarest aux états baltes voyez on va la
voir à l'écran la une de ce magazine
polonais d'un côté du combiné le
locataire d'élise et le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz de l'autre à
poutine se baignant dans le sang des
ukrainiens cruel outrancier injuste
certes ce qui instruit ce procès en
duplicité escamote un peu vite
l'engagement français militaire
humanitaire et financier reste qu'on a
vu surgir à kiev un néologisme féroce le
maquereau ning censé rallier la
propension à ensevelir l'inaction sous
les paroles au passage les russes loin
de se borner à piller les céréales de
l'ukraine ont aussi piqué cette
trouvaille à leurs voisins alors
pourquoi est ce que le président
français tient autant à murmurer alors à
l'oreille d'un sourd mais si mass macron
souscrit à l'analogie d'ailleurs bancal
avec le diktat infligée en 19 à berlin
l'allemagne paiera vous savez le ressort
du revanchisme hitlérien sans doute plus
manque t'il une claire conscience du
sens tragique de l'histoire question de
génération mais aussi de perception du
pouvoir la sienne reste ludique
transgressive et rationnelle lui semble
croire à la puissance performatif et 2,2
de son verbe quitte à oublier que les
obsessions poutinienne défie toute
raison les clés de l'intelligence si
aiguë soit celle ci n'ouvre pas ce genre
de coffre
il ya une énigme dans l'énigme pour
conclure pourquoi le français qui occupe
pour trois semaines encore la présence
de l'europe n'at-il toujours pas fait le
voyage de kiev alors ça viendra en temps
utile au bon moment répond son entourage
lui vaut de type en cela près le long
terme ce jour où les canons s'étant
enfin tu es bien on remettra sur les
rails le tortillard de la diplomatie
l'ennui c'est qu'avant l'après guerre il
y à la guerre alors à vrai dire moi j'ai
ignore si cette escapade ukrainienne
hypothétique serait utile ce dont je
suis sûr c'est que s'en abstenir serait
désastreux merci à vous vincent et je
françois caillé ménage vous êtes rendu
en ukraine pour la rédaction de tf1
plusieurs fois depuis début du conflit
une fois un petit mois 1 2 semaines
après le début du conflit à l'époque est
ce que il y avait déjà une forme de
ressentiment qui pouvaient s'exprimer
parmi la population vis-à-vis du chef de
l'état où on en était pas encore la
normale le mois où j'y suis allé il y
avait encore et j'ai croisé lens qui on
l'a interviewé dans son palais qui avait
vraiment cette idée que la france était
un des pays moteurs pour pour cette
guerre mais on sait tous chaque semaine
qu'avance et des rancoeurs
supplémentaire donc sur le front
diplomatique bien sûr mais je crois que
vu les urgences elles sont multiples ce
soit encore sur le terrain
tout émouvant c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire ça fait une semaine
aujourd'hui que le journaliste de bfm
frédéric leclerc imhoff a été tué on ne
craigne par un tir de l'armée russe
vous même vous l'avez peut-être croisé
sur le terrain quand vous y allez pour
l'avoir vu son son binôme maxime qui est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement de fabuleux et
et pour malheureusement sur notre
collègue de bfm moi je les ai vus en
cours une semaine à bordeaux donc
évidemment je suis comme toute la
profession fondé m'embarquer marqué ses
mots ma question c'est comment est ce
qu'on fait pour travailler dans un pays
où on sait qu'on est potentiellement la
cible de l'une des armées belligérantes
sur place je vais vous donner juste deux
exemples une fois de plus j'ai pas la
science infuse et sur ces terrains là
moi j'ai eu la chance d'en faire
plusieurs jeudi la chance entre
guillemets mais je vais vous donner
juste deux exemples quand on était nous
sur la ligne de front avec mes collègues
de tf1 on nous a demandé d'enlever les
étiquettes en scotch où il y avait écrit
tv presse parce que des forces
territoriale ukrainienne nous ont dit
c'est vous et les ambulances qui est
visé en premier donc enlever ça sinon on
est tous dans la merde y compris nous on
ne veut pas qu'ils aient écrit tv sur
une voiture ce qui est quand même
évidemment saisissant et malheureusement
aussi quand on est allé quinze jours
plus tôt dans ce quartier qui
entre-temps été dévastés et c'est ce que
j'appellerais la malchance on a croisé
dans nos images on l'a filmé le premier
journaliste qui est mort sur place qui
est mort cinq cents mètres plus loin et
qui malheureusement a continué sa route
et qui est mort d'une balle dans la
nuque
donc voilà il ya un facteur un moment
chance je rappelle aussi qu on est tous
volontaires pour partir et que des
civils eux n'ont rien demandé mais bon
toujours est il que l'effroi et le même
bien entendu merci beaucoup à vous tous
d'être venus sur le plateau des cpc la
fin de cette émission tout de suite
votre soirée documentaire avec un débat
doc qui est consacrée au métier
d'éducateur spécialisé
voilà je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée sur lcp
[Musique]